und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian
sieers guten Abend raus aus dem Horror
raus aus diesem abgeriegelten
Küstenstreifen raus aus Gaza seit Beginn
des Krieges ist das heute einer ersten
Gruppe von Menschen gelungen
schwerkranken und solchen mit
ausländischem Pass darunter auch
deutsche aber Taus weitereer warten auf
eine solche Chance zunehmend verzweifelt
denn die Bilder von Tod und Zerstörung
speziell im nördlichen Teil von Gaza
nehmen kein Ende wir beginnen unsere
Berichterstattung heute Abend in raffach
das ist der Grenzübergang im Süden aus
Gasa Richtung Ägypten und mit golinea
Thai ein Moment der Hoffnung etwas mehr
als 300 Menschen mit ausländischen
Pässen durften Gaza endlich verlassen
Australier Kanadier Jordanier unter
ihnen auch einzelne deutsche insgesamt
warten mehr als 300 deutsche noch immer
auf die Ausweise seit dem angefangen ste
an
gr Grenze dass ich da reinkomme aber
leider bis jetzt wir sind nur auf der
Straße wir haben keine Info wir rufen
den bchaft an keine antwortet und wollen
einfach zurück nach Deutschland mehr als
7000 doppelstler bangen und hoffen
weiter sie erzählen von getöteten
Verwandten von Leichen untertrümmern von
Chaos und
Leid wir haben nichts zu essen nichts zu
trinken keine Hilfen nichts wir bitten
die Welt auf uns zu schauen es gibt
Menschen hier die nur Gras Blätter oder
trockenes Brot
es gibt keinen Strom und damit auch kein
Internet die Lage ist einfach
entsetzlich
rund 80 verletzte standen heute
ebenfalls auf der ausreiseliste um in
Ägypten operiert zu werden die
Krankenhäuser in Gaza können viele
Operationen nicht mehr
durchführen der weil auf der ägyptischen
Seite LKW mit Medizin und Nahrung an
Bord stauen sich zwar dürfen in der
vierten Woche des Krieges etwas mehr
Hilfsgüter passieren aber immer noch
viel zu wenige sagen internation
Organisationen wie das Rote Kreuz
Ägypten ist bereit mehr Hilfe zu
schicken aber die israelische Seite
lehnt das stur ab sie hält sich nicht an
das
Völkerrecht mit Truppen und Panzern hat
Ägypten die Grenze zum gaserstreifen
aufgerüstet Betonmauern kreuz und quer
durch die Sinai Wüste gezogen direkt an
der Grenze machen die Ägypter klar wem
der Sina gehört den eigenen Einwohnern
und Beduinen die hier leben israel soll
aufhören Druck auszuüben um
Hunderttausende Palästinenser hier
aufzunehmen
Ägypten wird nicht zulassen dass Israel
die palästinensische Frage einfach auf
unserem Rücken
ablätt die Ägypter seinen bereit jeden
Zentimeter ihrer Sinai Wüste zu
verteidigen eine deutliche Botschaft in
Richtung des Nachbarn
Israel in der Nacht kommen weitere
Doppelstaatler aus Gasa über die Grenze
österreiche Briten und Amerikaner morgen
sollen die ausreisen
weitergehen Spirale der Gewalt das ist
so ein abwegiger Begriff weil er
suggeriert all das was wir aktuell
erleben würde quasi zwangsläufig auf
Autopilot passieren deshalb jetzt die
Stimme von einem der nach einem Ausweg
sucht er war vor zwei Tagen hier bei uns
im heute journal gerschon Baskin
israelischer Vermittler bei früheren
Verhandlungen mit Hamas man könne Hamas
besiegen indem man ihre Kommandeure
tötet sagt Baskin ihre zerstörerische
Ideologie kann aber nur dann besiegt
werden sagt er wenn die Palästinenser
ein Recht auf Selbstbestimmung bekommen
im Gebiet des historischen Palästina
müsse jede Person dieselben Rechte haben
Mehrheitsmeinung in Israel ist das eher
nicht Alisa jung hat sich in telaviv
umgehört an einem Tag an dem weitere
Nachrichten über die Folgen israelischer
Luftangriffe kommen
zweimal innerhalb von 24 Stunden wurde
das Viertel jabalia in Gaza von Israel
aus der Luft getroffen noch immer suchen
Sie nach
Verschütteten wir haben gebetet in der
Moschee dann haben wir die Explosion
gehört und gesehen dass alles weg ist es
ist ein
Massaker Israel spricht von einem
Dilemma für die Armee man wisse dass
sich in der Gegend Zivilisten aufhielten
obwohl sie gewarnt worden sei Ziel sei
Kommandozentrum der Hamas gewesen so die
Armee einen ihrer Führer habe man töten
und tunnelstrukturen bei dem Angriff
zerstören
können Außenministerin berbock
wiederholt im ZDF was nun das Recht
Israels auf Selbstverteidigung und sagt
man müsse Empathie zeigen dass es
überall Opfer gebe wenn wir dafür sorgen
wollen dass Israel endlich in Frieden
und Sicherheit leben kann wie jedes Land
auf der Welt wenn wir dafür sorgen
wollen dass Palästinenser endlich auch
in Sicherheit und Frieden frei von Hamas
leben können dann müssen wir bereit sein
uns immer wieder in die Schuhe des
anderen auchzustellen doch Israel
vermisst dass die Welt ihren Schmerz und
die Bedrohung
versteht was würden Sie tun wenn jemand
am Samstag morgen kommt und einfach 1400
Menschen tötet einfach so unschuldige
die nichts gemacht haben niemand etwas
Böses getan haben Israel fragt sich was
heißt ihr steht an unserer
Seite
wenn wir sie so behandeln sollen wie sie
uns behandelt haben sollen wir
vergewaltigen sollen wir Köpfe abpacken
sollen wir ihre Häuser verbrennen was
können wir machen was können wir machen
wenn es dein Haus wäre was würdest du
machen wollen Sie wissen wenn es euer
Land und eure Kinder wären während viele
der internationalen Gemeinschaft der
Meinung sind beides muss gehen
Zivilisten schützen und Israel
schützen bringen wir Experten und
Chefredakteur der Fachzeitschrift Zenit
mit dazu Daniel Gerlach heute live aus
Alexandria in Ägypten guten Abend Daniel
ja hallo die dilemmafrage die wir gerade
schon kurz angesprochen gehört haben
vielleicht zuerst Israel wird einerseits
zugestanden sich gegen Hamas Terror zu
wehren und gleichzeitig wächst
international die Kritik daran wie es
das tut gibt's da für Israel einen
Ausweg ich denke schon wenn der auch
nicht einfach ist wir müssen uns
anschauen was hat ja was hat die
israelische Regierung bisher erreicht
sie hat es wenn man den letzten
Berichten glauben schenkt oder auch dem
hört dem zuhört was aus der Armee kommt
es immerhin geschafft zu verhindern dass
Hamas jetzt unmittelbar Israel wieder
angreifen und bedrohen kann indem es
Hamas so geschwächt hat dass zumindest
die militärische Kapazität momentan
nicht besteht oder sehr eingeschränkt
ist und am Anfang haben die Israelis
gesagt Sie wollen ihre ihr
abschreckungspotenzial wiederherstellen
auch das ist ein bisschen äh in den
Hintergrund gerückt aber es ist
offensichtlicher erreicht jetzt kommt
aber der Punkt wo die Israelis
eigentlich Dinge er oder wo netanahu
Dinge erreichen möchte die sich
gegenseitig widersprechen er möchte auf
der einen Seite das Leben der Geiseln
schonen er möchte auf der anderen Seite
dafür sorgen dass die eigene Armee
geschont wird also dass sie nicht so
viele Opfer bei der Militäroperation
haben und er möchte die Hamas vernichten
und diese Ziele die sind eigentlich
konträr zueinander und da muss die
internationale Gemeinschaft glaube ich
nicht nur den Israelis sondern allen
Seiten irgendwie eine Möglichkeit geben
da gesichtswarend raus zu kommen und
diese Ziele in irgendeiner Form zu
priorisieren und das ist ein Moment für
krisendiplomatie momentan wie glaube ich
selten in der Welt besteht wo sehr sehr
viele Mächte Miteinander mit anpacken
müssen und sehr geschickt im Hintergrund
agieren müssen inklusive die israelische
Seite ein Moment für
krisendiplomatie man sieht allerdings
eher einen Rückzug der Diplomatie
aktuell wenn man noch nach Jordanien
gucken Jordanien war das zweite Land das
einen Friedensvertrag mit Israel
abgeschlossen hat dass die das zweite
arabische Land das diplomatisch
Beziehungen zu Israel aufgenommen hat
jordanien ist gleichzeitig ein wichtiger
us-verbündeter in der Region jetzt ruft
Jordanien seinen Botschafter aus Israel
zurück Gerät da gerade etwas Gewaltiges
ins
Rutschen Jordanien steht extrem unter
Druck es ist auch interessant wie die
verschiedenen Staaten der Region mit der
Situation umgehen hier wo ich gerade bin
in Ägypten habe ich den Eindruck dass
die nachrichtenberichterstattung recht
zurückhaltend ist man möchte
offensichtlich man weiß dass die Lune
kurz ist und man möchte kein Öl insfeuer
Gießen in Jordanien ist ein ist der
Großteil der Bevölkerung
palästinensischen Ursprungs Jordanien
fühlt sich unmittelbar betroffen die die
Königin ist selbst Palästinenserin und
ich glaube das ist noch eine andere
Situation in der Türkei z.B da haut
Präsident Erdogan ordentlich auf den
Putz und führt einen viel viel
schärferen Diskurs noch als in vielen
arabischen Ländern zu dem Thema also die
staten halten sich unterschiedlich aber
es gibt immer diejenigen die im
Vordergrund poltern und es gibt
diejenigen die im Hintergrund eben
geschickt versuchen doch irgendwie die
verschiedenen Interessen übereinander zu
bringen und das ist n n mal so bei
solchen Krisensituation aber die gibt es
eben auch die Amerikaner die Kataris
auch die Ägypter auch israelische
Sicherheitskräfte z.B die Geheimdienste
die versuchen einige Ziele zu erreichen
wie z.B zumindest die zivilen Geiseln
aus Gaza nochmen und das ist wichtig
dass man auch auf diese Seite guckt und
nicht nur darauf schaut wer gerade
poltert und versucht eben der
öffentlichen Meinung vorauszulaufen sie
haben die USA gerade angesprochen über
die müssen wir auf jeden Fall noch reden
sie sind ja mit Abstand der wichtigste
Verbündete von Israel in der Welt da
gibt's heute einen wirklich se sehr
bemerkenswerten Satz des amerikanischen
Außenministers Tony blinken er hat
gesagt ich zitiere ihn wörtlich mehr als
2 Millionen palästinensische Zivilisten
im Gazastreifen haben nichts mit den
abscheulichen Terrorangriffen der Hamas
vom 7 Oktober zu tun ihnen kann man die
Grausamkeiten der Hamas nicht vorwerfen
sie sind selbst Opfer das sehen wir wir
vorhin gesehen haben ja viele in Israel
komplett anders wie kommt denn so ein
Satz an welche Wirkung hat der auf
israels
Regierung ich weiß nicht welche auf die
Regierung hat ich glaube auf die
Regierung hatten haben nicht diese
öffentlich geäußerten sätzewikung
sondern das was man eben im Hintergrund
miteinander bespricht es ist ja
letztendlich erstmal völlig normal ich
glaube nicht möchte jetzt nicht
emotionalisieren aber ich glaube nicht
dass ein achtjähriges Kind was durch
einen Bombenangriff in Gaza ums Leben
kommt irgendetwas mit der Hamas zu tun
hat und viele der Opfer die dort sterben
haben nichts mit der Hamas zu tun und
wie man statistisch auch weiß will ein
Großteil der Bevölkerung des
gaserastreifens ja nicht die Herrschaft
der Hammers man möchte aber auch nicht
als altern die Besatzung oder die
Eskalation des Krieges das bedeutet also
die Israelis müssen Maß halten und es
ist eben nicht so wie im Vorfeld gesagt
wurde unmittelbar nach dem 7 Oktober
auch für die israelische israelische
Diplomatie in Deutschland gesagt hat man
wolle sich jetzt nicht von der
internationalen Gemeinschaft sagen oder
vorschreiben lassen wie man auf diesen
Terror reagiert natürlich findet das
ganze in einem in einem Zusammenwirken
von Staaten statt die auch voneinander
abhängig sind auch Israel braucht einige
der arabischen Staaten der Region und
deswegen wirkt natürlich die
internationale Gemeinschaft hier mit und
da glaube ich nicht nur Empathie zu
zeigen für beide Seiten wie die
bundesaußenministerin eben in im Beitrag
gesagt hat sondern muss man auch ganz
konkret auf die Konfliktparteien
einwirken am schwierigsten ist es glaube
ich momentan nicht unbedingt auf die
Israelis einzuwirken sondern auf die
Hamas einzuwirken aber auch da gibt es
eben Möglichkeiten das zu tun die Stunde
der Diplomatie könnte eben aktuell auch
geschlagen haben sagt Daniel Gerlach
Chefredakteur der Fachzeitschrift Zenit
dan herzlichen Dank für diese Analyse ja
vielen
dankr ostkonflikt beschäftigt die Welt
und wühlt sie auf anders kann man das
nicht sagen ich habe heute tatsächlich
an der Supermarktkasse eine Diskussion
darüber erlebt manche suchen nach
Informationen bemühen sich Hintergründe
zu erfahren und manche sind für Fakten
und Zusammenhänge nicht mehr erreichbar
und zwar auf beiden Seiten Claudia Bates
berichtet jetzt über die Situation in
den USA wo der FBI Chef sagt der
Antisemitismus habe historische Ausmaße
erreicht insbesondere an den teuren
Eliteunis dort wo der Nachwuchs für die
wichtigsten Positionen im Land studiert
läuft die Diskussion völlig aus dem
Ruder die Stimmung aufgeladen hitzige
Auseinandersetzungen der Mann der
anderer Meinung ist wird
niedergeschrien denn sie stehen sich
unversöhnlich gegenüber die
proalästinensischen Studenten und die
proisraelischen Studenten an der
Columbia Universität in New York und so
wie hier ist ist es an vielen
Universitäten im ganzen Land jüdische
Studenten wurden bereits angegriffen und
geschlagen mussten sich vor einem
wütenden Mob
verstecken wir wissen jetzt dass in
unseren Kursen Studenten sitzen die uns
hassen nur weil wir jüdisch
sind auch an der renommierten Harvard
Universität Proteste für diesen Teil der
jungen Elite ist Israel ein
Kolonialstaat ein Apartheit Regime das
allein für die Gewalt im Nahen Osten
verantwortlich ist von Genozid
Völkermord an Palästinensern ist hier
die Rede von den greulteltaten der Hamas
nicht jüdische Studenten im ganzen Land
in
Sorge es gibt bei uns Studenten die
explizit und mit Namen sagen dass andere
Studenten langsam sterben
sollen an der idylischen Cornell
University eine Flut von massiven
Drohungen auf dem onlineeportal der Uni
man solle jüdischen Männern die Kehle
durchschneiden die Frauen vergewaltigen
jemand soll ein Sturmgewehr mitbringen
und alle jüdischen Studenten erschießen
Polizeiwagen stehen jetzt überall auf
dem Gelände das FBI wurde eingeschaltet
ein Verdächtiger ist gefasst ein Student
seine komelitonen
fassungslos solche abscheuliche
Drohungen das ist ein Versuch uns
auseinanderzut treiben aber ich möchte
meinen Mitstudenten nicht anschauen und
denken das ist mein Feind ich möchte
einfach denken das ist mein
Mitstudent antisemitische Angriffe sind
in den USA um fast 400% gestiegen in den
letzten Wochen so eine jüdische
Bürgerrechts
Organisation bei einer Anhörung im
Kongress erläutert Außenminister blinken
die Unterstützung für Israel auch hier
schlagen die Wogen hoch er sei der
Terrorist schreit eine protestierende
und habe Blut an den Händen die
US-Regierung ist
alarmiert wir werden alles tun um sowohl
an der Cornell Universität wie im ganzen
Land Antisemitismus zu
bekämpfen Professor hat dazu aufgerufen
diesen Studenten nach ihrer
eliteausbildung keine Jobs zu geben und
zahlungskräftige Spender haben bereits
gedroht ihre großzügige Unterstützung
für die Hochschulen
einzustellen wir bleiben noch ein Moment
bei diesem traugen Thema mit dir Hanna
ja und schauen nach Wien dort ermittelt
nun nämlich nach einem mutmaßlichen
Brandanschlag auf den jüdischen Teil des
Zentralfriedhofs der Verfassungsschutz
laut Polizei war das Feuer in der Nacht
ausgebrochen verletzt wurde niemand
zudem wurde die Friedhofsmauer mit
antisemitischen Symbolen besprüht
Österreichs Bundespräsident van der
Bellen beklagte dass die Zahl der
antisemitischen Vorfälle in Österreich
in den letzten Wochen signifikant
gestiegen sei in Deutschland sollen
geflüchtete künftig früher arbeiten
dürfen das hat das Bundeskabinett heute
beschlossen der Vorschlag von
Innenministerin fäser sieht unter
anderem vor dass Asylbewerber die in
erstaufnahmeeinrichtungen Leben bereits
nach 6 statt nach
Monaten arbeiten dürfen zudem sollen
geduldete im Regelfall eine
Arbeitserlaubnis bekommen fragen wir
nach bei Valerie Haller was die
Wirtschaft zu diesen Plänen sagt ist das
ein wirksames Mittel gegen den
Fachkräftemangel also zumindest ein
Baustein kann es sein was das in Zahlen
bedeutet darauf wollte sich ja auch die
Innenministerin heute nicht festnageln
lassen Arbeitsmarktforscher jedenfalls
halten die neuen Regeln für einen
Schritt in die richtige Richtung weil
sich der Kreis derjenigen die nun
arbeiten dürfen dadurch deutlich
erweitern werde war aber gleichzeitig
vor zu großen Erwartungen ja und ähnlich
argumentiert der Deutsche
Gewerkschaftsbund der sich
perspektivisch für noch mehr
Arbeitsmöglichkeiten von geflüchteten
ausspricht ja und aus der Wirtschaft ist
zu hören dass die Reform sinnvoll se sei
mahnt aber an dass Behörden unter
anderem bei den Asylverfahren schneller
werden müssten für mehr
Planungssicherheit in Unternehmen
weiterer Beschluss des Kabinetts ist
eine Verlängerung der
energiepreisbremse wie sind da die
Reaktionen ziemlich verhalten Verbände
bezweifeln dass die Verlängerung
pünktlich zum 1 Januar umgesetzt werden
kann weil die EU-Kommission und der
Bundestag noch zustimmen müssen und dann
müssen Versorger und Stadtwerke noch
ihre Abrechnungssysteme anpessen und
Kunden informieren das könnte eng werden
das Kabinett will auch an anderer Stelle
entlasten indem es nämlich die
Netzentgelte subventioniert aber dieser
Effekt könnte verpuffen denn die
Netzbetreiber planen trotz Finanzspritze
vom Staat eine Erhöhung wegen
gestiegener Kosten das bedeutet de facto
Strom wird nächstes Jahr vermutlich
teurer wegen der Subventionen nur nicht
ganz so viel vielen Dank Valerie für
diese
Einordnungen pakistan hat nach eigenen
Angaben mit den angedrohten
Abschiebungen von Flüchtlingen ohne
aufenthalsstatus begonnen dies betrifft
vor allem Afghanen zuvor war den
geflüchteten eine Frist bis zum 1
November gesetzt worden um das Land
freiwillig zu verlassen an der Grenze
bildeten sich deshalb auch heute lange
Staus in Pakistan leben laut Regierung
rund 1,7 Millionen Afghanen ohne gültige
Papiere mehr als 100.000 sollen das Land
bereits verlassen haben nach der
Machtübernahme der Taliban waren viele
Afghanen in das Nachbarland
geflüchtet wenn man am falschen Ende
spart dann zahlt man drauf altes
Sprichwort gilt möglicherweise auch für
die politische Bildung in Deutschland
für nüchterne Information in Zeiten von
Fake News und Zulauf für radikale in ein
Jahrzehnt lang ist z.B der Etat der
Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung
stetig gestiegen jetzt soll er gekürzt
werden und zwar gleich um 20% im
kommenden Jahr sparen halt es gibt die
die sagen es sei immer noch viel Geld im
System und der Erfolg solcher
Bildungsmaßnahmen lasse sich auch nicht
wirklich überprüfen es gibt auch die die
nicht verstehen wieso man ausgerechnet
jetzt ausgerechnet hier sparen will
Nicola Albrecht berichtet
die 3dbrille macht es möglich echte
Zeitzeugen vermitteln virtuell ihre
Erlebnisse aus dem Dritten Reich und
Schüler treffen auf diese Weise hautnah
eine Holocaust Überlebende und da kommt
dann ein junger Mann in SS Uniform und
geht an meine Schwester vorbei und haut
dem Kind ein auf den Kopf mit seinem
jekol diese Wanderausstellung ist
aktuell in Brandenburg unterwegs und
trifft an diesem Morgen auf Schüler
manche von ihnen wollen nicht gezeigt
werden denn sie berichten uns dass
rechtes Gedankengut längst Alltag auf
ihrem Schulhof sei du Jude ein gängiges
Schimpfwort hakenkreuzer an der
schulwand nicht selten die die eben halt
rechts sind und diese
Ansichten vertreten viel zu großen
Resonanzraum bekommen weil einfach die
Mehrheit nichts dazu sagt und einfach
schweigt und es gewähren lässt Projekte
wie diese werden 2024 möglicherweise
nicht mehr stattfinden denn die
Fördermittel dafür will die Regierung
drastisch kürzen insgesamt 130 Millionen
Euro weniger für Projekte in der
politischen Bildung sieht der
Haushaltsetat künftig vor obgleiches im
Koalitionsvertrag heißt Zitat wir werden
die Arbeit zur Bekämpfung von
Rechtsextremismus und Rassismus
fortsetzen inhaltlich weiterentwickeln
und sie nachhaltig finanziell absichern
Wilfried klein vertritt die Interessen
der politischen Bildungsträger die
Sparmaßnahmen kämen zur Unzeit das ist
ein völlig fatales Signal in dieser Zeit
und das habe ich auch schon gesagt bevor
jetzt durch den Angriff der Hamas auf
Israel sich auch bei uns die
gesellschaftspolitischen Spannung weiter
erhöht haben wir leben in einer Zeit
massiver
Umbrüche und sie fordern die
Gesellschaft massiv heraus und in dieser
Situation an der politischen Bildung
sparen zu wollen
ist ein großer Fehler der dort von der
Ampelkoalition auf den Weg gebracht
worden ist viele Projekte werden von der
Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung
finanziert die Bundeszentrale liegt im
Geschäftsbereich des Innenministeriums
und wurde bereits 1952 gegründet für
Demokratie und gegen totalitäre
Ideologien sie soll ab kommendem Jahr
mit rund 20% weniger Budget
auskommen was lässt sich aus der
Geschichte lernen z.B aus der Geschichte
von Anne Frank das Erarbeiten Schüler
bundesweit am
wir können sehr viel lernen wir können
lernen immer positiv zu denken wir
können lernen stark zu bleiben stark
sein für Freiheit Toleranz und gegen
Antisemitismus der Anne franktag
erreicht jedes Jahr 100ta000
Schülerinnen doch die Förderung für das
kommende Jahr wurde bislang nicht
bewilligt unsere Hauptzielgruppe Kinder
und Jugendliche befähgen wir sich selbst
als Akteure der Demokratie wahrzunehmen
und eben eigene Projekte umzusetzen das
ist ein sehr über die Jahre
auch wirklich wichtiger und effektiver
Weg dieses Thema zu bearbeiten und
Demokratie zu stärken die politischen
Bildungsinstitutionen hoffen nun auf die
abschließende Haushaltsberatung im
November und dass ihre Arbeit doch wie
bisher weiter finanziert
wird ja noch ist nichts definitiv
entschieden in der Sache jetzt noch mal
du Hanna die usnotenbank Fett lässt den
Leitzins zum zweiten Mal inf Folge
unverändert er bleibt damit in einer
Spanne von 5,25 bis
5,5%. wegen der hohen Inflation hatte
die Fett den Leitzins seit März 2022 11
Mal angehoben in den letzten zwei
Monaten lag die teurerungsrate in den
USA bei
3,7%. in der zweiten Runde des DFB
Pokals ging es auch heute um den Einzug
ins Achtelfinale mit zahlreichen
Begegnungen und auch schon einigen
Ergebnissen Borussia Dortmund besiegte
TSG Hoffenheim mit 1 zu zu n0 der SV
Sandhausen ist raus der drittliges traf
auf Bayern Leverkusen Endstand 2:5
holsteinkiiel verlor im Meter Schießen
gegen den ersten fC Magdeburg mit 3:4
der SC Freiburg hat es nicht ins
Achtelfinale geschafft gegen den SC
Paderborn stand es am Ende
1:3 zu den Lottozahlen an diesem
Mittwoch die lauten 8 20 26 33 43 49
Superzahl
alle Angaben wie immer ohne
Gewehr er war der wohlbekannteste
Zauberer der DDR und begeisterte sein
Publikum mit Fernsehsendungen wie Zauber
auf Schloss kuckustein nun ist der
Magier Peter Kersten im Alter von 80
Jahren gestorben nach der Wende wurde er
als the magic doctor auch dem
gesamtdeutschen Fernsehpublikum bekannt
hierbei musik liegt in der Luft im ZDF
die verschwundene Dame war eine seiner
spezialit
[Applaus]
da ist sie wieder Ambitionen habe sie
noch nie gehabt sagt die Schauspielerin
Sandra Hüller in einem Interview ganz
bescheiden und vielleicht ist das ja das
Geheimnis ihres Erfolges denn gleich
zwei Filme in denen sie mitspielt haben
beim Festival in khn die wichtigsten
Preise abgeräumt der Gewinner der
Goldenen Palme ist dieser hier Anatomie
eines Falls heißt das Gerichtsdrama das
morgen auch bei uns in Deutschland in
die Kinos kommt Nadja nasser hat mehr
ich will dass du eins weißt ich bin kein
Monster weißt du Sandra eine Ehefrau und
Mutter wird des Mordes verdächtigt es
ist ein rätselhafter Fall ihr Mann
Samuel ist zu Tode gestürzt aus dem
obersten Fenster ihres Hauses Sohn
Daniel findet den toten Vater im Schnee
was ist passiert in dem einsamen Chalet
in den französischen Alpen war es ein
Unfall war es Selbstmord oder doch doch
die Ehefrau ich habe ihn nicht
getötet der Film wirft so viele Fragen
auf ohne einen an der Nase herumzuführen
es wird ja
geschafft nichts zu beantworten im
Grunde und trotzdem bleibt die Spannung
die ganze Zeit erhalten geben Sie zu
dass er eifersüchtig war folgt man ihrer
Logik waren alle Probleme von Samuel
meine Schuld Sandra muss sich vor
Gericht verteidigen und ihre
unkonventionelle Einstellung zu Ehe und
Familie Anatomie eines falls ist eine
schonungslose Analyse einer Beziehung da
ist der verstorbene Ehemann Samuel der
von einer Karriere als Schriftsteller
träumte und scheiterte und daneben die
selbstbewusste Sandra die mit ihren
Romanen Erfolge feierte dazwischen Sohn
Daniel der nach einem Unfall fast
erblindet
ist waren sie wütend auf ihren Mann nach
dem tragischen Unfall ihres Sohnes ja
für einige Tage er war für ihn
verantwortlich nur einige Tage ihr Sohn
hat sein Augenlicht fast völlig verloren
und sie waren nur einige Tage lang
wütend die Idee war tatsächlich das
Leben dieser Frau dieses Paares
aufzudecken im Rahmen eines
Gerichtsprozesses interessanterweise
werden Frauen ja immer sehr viel härter
beurteilt vor allem Frauen die sich
ihren Platz in der Gesellschaft einfach
so nehmen ohne um Erlaubnis zu fragen
Sandra Hüller spielt die Frau auf der
Anklagebank so vielschichtig eine
Meisterleistung als eine Tonaufnahme von
einem heftigen it vor Gericht abgespielt
wird gerät sie weiter unter Druck ich
habe überhaupt keine Zeit für mich
verstehst du
das du beschwerst dich über dein Leben
dass du die ausgesucht hast du bist kein
Opfer gar keins klar du bist brutal ich
bin brutal was eine Person im Publikum
selbst denkt welche Moralvorstellungen
sie oder er hat welche Grenzen sie oder
er wichtig findet oder so das wird in
dem Film dann gesehen also die Figur
verändert sich nach zuschauendeen
Menschen und das finde ich total
interessant also
dass die zuschauenden quasi mitspielen
mit denken und mit ja sich dabei
ertappen dass sie urteilen Anatomie
eines Falls ist ein spannender Thriller
und packendes Gesellschaftsdrama mit
einer herausragenden Sandra Hüller hab
diese Woche im Kino und im
auslandsjournal gleich nach uns hier im
Fernsehen ein Elitesoldat aus deuts
der jetzt für Israels Armee im Einsatz
ist es lohnt sich also weiter hier im
ZDF zu bleiben unter anderem für eine
ausführliche Reportage unseres Israel
Korrespondenten Michael Beverunger und
natürlich auch für unser heute journal
Update gegen 0:30 Uhr mit NAS g mir bis
morgen wenn Sie mögen und für heute vom
gesamten Team einen angenehmen Abend
tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend der Oktober war
deutschlandweit etwa anderthalb mal so
nass wie üblich im vieljährigen
Klimamittel dabei gab es große regionale
Unterschiede in Norddeutschland fiel zum
Teil das Doppelte bis das Dreifache des
üblichen in Südostbayern waren es kaum
die hälftte noch spannender als der
Rückblick ist allerdings die Vorschau
und da kommt jetzt ein Orkantief an das
landet hier gerade an den Westküsten von
Irland Großbritannien und Frankreich an
dieses Orkantief es heißt international
kiren Deutsch Emir wird bis morgen Abend
die Nordsee erreicht haben es bringt
Orkanböhen bis 200 km pro Stunde mit und
10 m hohe Wellen an den Küsten das
bedeutet die Infrastruktur wird in
Mitleidenschaft gezogen werden und Bäume
werden Umstürzen uns wird dieses
Orkantief nur streifen heute Nacht
gibt's einige Regenschauer in der
Westhälfte sonst ist es meist trocken
Temperaturen sinken auf 10 bis 2° und
morgen wird es mild die Höchstwerte
liegen zwischen 9° an den Alpen und 16°
in der lausis schon am Vormittag beginnt
es von Westen kräftig zu regnen und es
wird ein starker bis stürmischer Wind
auf den Bergen gibt's auch sturmböhen im
Osten ist es dagegen noch trocken in
Süddeutschland gibt's dann am Nachmittag
noch kräftigen Regen einige Schauer an
der Nordseeküste und in den nächsten Tag
geht es wechselhaft windig und recht
mild weiter guten Abend